let's run through a couple of other
funny clips in the time that we have we
have a lot to get to today but there's a
few other things from the last week that
i did not
get to that i want to first of all here
is cnn host chris cuomo
who invited republican senator from
texas ted cruz on his program and they
got into it
and at one point when ted cruz
started going after chris cuomo's
brother andrew cuomo chris cuomo brings
up
trump said your wife's ugly and of
course it's true
recall the story back from the campaign
where donald trump
uh did indeed uh send out a tweet
saying implying saying that joe biden
that ted cruz's wife not joe biden's
wife although it wouldn't shock me to
hear trump talk about joe biden's wife
but no that ted cruz's wife
um is is unattractive and
here is cruz being interviewed by chris
cuomo mixing it up
cruz tries to attack cuomo over his
brother being andrew cuomo and cuomo
doesn't doesn't go for it take a look
does that make you plausible
troubles me ted to watch guys like you
stand by
and stroke your beard like a wise man
instead of telling the president to get
on it when you have power to get on it
my brother will stand why don't you talk
to the president the way you talk to my
brother ted
you afraid of him do you think he'll
smack you down at home
is that what it is like he's terrified
you guys are really
talking about the president my brother's
not the president i'm talking about the
president
the one who called you a liar the one
who said your wife is ugly that guy you
know the
guy now you won't say anything about i i
recognize that you like
you actually wonder why you don't have a
lot of republicans that want to come on
your show i have more than any other
show
that's okay chris you're perfectly fine
to scream and yell because you know what
you don't you're doing it because you
don't want to discuss the substance like
you invited me on the show to actually
talk about the supreme court and talk
about the book one vote away
it is indeed true uh donald trump
back during the 2016 republican primary
tweeted out a picture of ted cruz's wife
alongside
melania trump with the message a picture
is worth a thousand words very
unflattering
image of ted cruz's wife and eventually
ted cruz still got in line and still
supported donald trump and he doesn't
want to talk about that incident now
with chris cuomo
there are right-wingers that are mad at
cuomo here
good on chris cuomo i say and
[Music]
way to go calling out ted cruz when cruz
tries to pivot to talking about andrew
cuomo remind him that trump called his
wife ugly
and we've talked about this before why
is it that these people who trump
brutally and disgustingly attacks even
attacking their families
how is it they get in line and support
trump is it because they see trump as
the only path to power and they don't
want to be on the outside they're
desperate to be on the inside
is it that trump goes to them with some
kind of compelling case that he makes
does trump apologize to them behind the
scenes i can't imagine i've never seen
trump apologize publicly
for anything ever so it's hard to
believe that's the explanation i don't
know what it is
but i'm curious to hear what what you
think
why do these people that are viciously
attacked by trump on a personal level
right
i mean the kamala biden thing okay
saying biden was racially insensitive it
is a personal attack in a sense because
it goes to who joe biden is
but it was all very clearly politics and
about the things
joe biden did as as an elected official
as a legislator
saying your wife is ugly is a different
caliber it's a different
game altogether that's being played and
cruz just fell in line and supports
trump and goes out and does his dirty
work
let me know what you think explains it
every single day
the trump administration shows us what
happens when anti-science
christian conservatives have power in
government on everything from
climate change to fighting this pandemic
we cannot afford another four years of
donald trump one of our sponsors today
is the free thought equality super pac
both they and i want to remind you that
voting against donald trump in the
presidential election
is one of the most important things you
can do right now if you want
religious conservatives to have less
power and you want science to have more
influence in government
make sure you're registered to vote make
the commitment to vote
on or before november 3rd i also
encourage you to check out the center
for free thought equality
which is an advocacy group that promotes
evidence-based public policy
and supports secular candidates running
for office becoming a member is
completely free
gives you access to tons of excellent
resources related
to secularism in politics just visit
cfequality.org
you can find the link right underneath
this video this message
was paid for by the free thought
equality super pac
and is not authorized by any candidate
or candidates committee